allez maintenant direction
l'Arménie pour notre second débat
l'Arménie attaqué par son voisin
laserbaïdjan qui tente de mobiliser la
communauté internationale dans
l'équation je vous le disais en titre il
y a une donnée qui freine l'indignation
qui freine les sanctions c'est le gaz
venu de Bakou ce gaz dans l'Europe a
besoin avant d'en débattre je vous
propose un point de la situation sur
place lundi Vladimir Poutine réunissait
le Premier ministre arménien et le
président Azer bayjanais ils se sont
engagés à ne plus recourir à la force
c'est un conflit de plus de 30 ans pour
comprendre ce qui oppose aujourd'hui
l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïdjan il faut
remonter à l'époque soviétique dans les
années 20 l'URSS dessine les frontières
de son empire éveillent à ce qu'aucune
République ne puisse se retrouver en
position dominante
situer un carrefour stratégique du
Caucase l'Arménie se voit alors séparé
d'une partie de sa population celle du
ok rabat rattachée à l'Azerbaïdjan
il a donc défini le territoire de
l'Arménie tel qu'il existe à l'heure
actuelle et il a détaché une région qui
était peuplée à majorité par des
Arméniens depuis plusieurs siècles avant
Jésus-Christ qui s'appelle le carabar il
l'a rattaché à l'Azerbaïdjan mais pour
ne pas non plus trop favoriser
l'Azerbaïdjan il a fait de cette région
peuplée en majorité d'Arméniens une
région autonome les abeilles jaunes ne
veut pas d'une région autonome sur son
territoire le conflit pour le contrôle
du haut-karaba éclate dès la fin de
l'empire soviétique avec plus de 30000
morts dans les années 90 et depuis les
guerres se succèdent dernier épisode en
date septembre 2022 pour la première
fois les combats s'exportent à la
frontière entre les deux pays tuant 2
personnes en deux jours
réunissent ce week-end à Sotchi en
Russie les deux États se sont engagés à
ne plus recourir à la violence
la réunion a été utile et crée les
conditions pour de nouvelles avancées
vers un règlement général de la
situation je regroupe
de 2500 soldats russes de maintien de la
paix n'a pas empêché les violences de
septembre dernier
concentré ces derniers mois sur le
conflit ukrainien la Russie tente de
reprendre la main sur ce terrain qu'elle
a délaissé c'est ce qu'on appelle en
relation internationale une instabilité
contrôlée
les Russes font laisse les azériés faire
peur aux Arméniens et de l'autre côté
se proclame défenseur des Arméniens
contre les azéries de façon à
constamment être les intervenants
indispensables de la zone parce que tout
simplement l'Arménie c'est la route
aussi directement ouverte vers l'Iran
l'Iran un intérêt tout particulier pour
la Russie Téhéran est accusé d'avoir
livré des armes à Moscou utiliser contre
l'Ukraine
je vous présente les invités de notre
débat Valérie Boyer bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes sénatrice LRD Bouches-du-Rhône
Valérie toragnan directrice de la Revue
des Deux Mondes bonsoir bienvenue à vous
aussi Guillaume Daret et restez à mes
côtés toujours là et toujours éditoris
politique et on accueille dans un cours
instant le géographe Jean rad Vany je
vous propose une carte peut-être ça fait
toujours du bien quand on parle de de
cette partie du monde le Caucase voilà
l'Arménie l'Azerbaïdjan depuis en
conflit depuis des décennies de pays qui
vous le voyez sont bordés alors faudrait
presque dézoomer un peu son bordé par la
Russie et la Géorgie au nord l'Iran au
sud on l'a vu la Turquie à l'ouest et
puis je vous propose de voir
une carte qui intègre les dernières
attaques mi-septembre 13 14 septembre
alors on n'est pas dans ce haut Karaba
qui est qui est source de conflit depuis
si longtemps dans la région on est à la
frontière vraiment entre l'Arménie et
l'Azerbaïdjan et notamment dans dans le
couloir de la Chine Valérie Boyer cette
attaque elle a fait près de 300 morts
l'Azerbaïdjan a repris 50 km² de
territoire dans une quasi indifférence
internationale on peut le dire même s'il
y a eu bon voilà quelques voies qui se
sont élevés qu'est-ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans ces territoires
qu'est-ce que vous savez de la situation
dans ces 50 km² là qui ont été repris
par par l'Azerbaïdjan
il est territoires ne sont pas repris
par la serbaïdjan ils sont pris à
l'Arménie c'est pas du tout la même
chose on n'est pas dans un on n'est pas
dans le conflit gelé de duo Karaba de la
ksark on est sur la République d'Arménie
qui est reconnue par la communauté
internationale donc c'est une attaque en
règle compte un pays démocratique est
souverain donc c'est pas la même chose
aujourd'hui il se passe que les
Arméniens très affectés par le la guerre
des 44 jours en septembre
octobre fin octobre
c'était pour le pour le au Caraba
dans des conditions particulièrement
sales de la part de l'Azerbaïdjan il
faut le rappeler qui est un état
corrompu et raciste
qui ne cache pas ses dessins
d'extermination des Arméniens c'est
vraiment une volonté de nettoyage
ethnique même de poursuite du génocide
le grand ami de dalief donc le président
de l'État le président auto-proclamé
d'Azerbaïdjan qui est
Erdogan membre de l'OTAN parle des
Arméniens comme des restes de l'épée les
restes de l'épée ça veut dire tous ceux
qui ne sont pas morts pendant que
génocide donc on voit bien qu'ils sont
dans une poursuite génocidaire dont il
ne se cache pas dont il se vante et même
une sorte de guerre de religion de
guerre ethnique et de guerre donc ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui mais c'est que
l'Arménie est assez seul même seul face
à ce puissant voisin
très riche de son gaz qui est très riche
parce que c'est aussi un état qui
pratique la diplomatie de la menace et
la corruption où tout le monde enfin
personne n'ignore ce qu'est la caviar
connection la diplomatie du caviar etc
qui touche tous les pays du monde la
France compris d'ailleurs ça a été
documenté par pas mal de vos confrères
donc effectivement l'Arménie est assez
seul et contrairement à l'Ukraine elle
n'a pas d'aide internationale elle n'a
pas d'armes elle n'a pas non plus de
déclaration dans les grandes instances
internationales on y reviendra en détail
à la fois cette cet impact du gaz du gaz
azerbaïdjanais je vais vous donner la
parole dans un instant et et aussi
évidemment de l'influence de la Turquie
Valérie thoragnon je voudrais quand même
entendre assez vite votre témoignage
parce que vous étiez en Arménie il y a
quelques il y a quelques jours c'est ça
dans quel état il y a deux semaines dans
quel état d'esprit avez-vous trouvé les
habitants donc c'était après on est bien
d'accord les les attaques dont on a
parlé
écoutez j'ai trouvé des gens
extraordinairement
impressionnants parce que
les villages qu'on a visité à la
frontière donc là où il y a eu à
quelques kilomètres des affrontements
sont des gens dans les villages où
j'étais qui sont
qui se réfugient dans des grottes c'est
des anciens villages troglodytes donc il
y a dans les dans les dans la roche dans
la montagne des des cavités dans
laquelle il se réfugie ils y sont restés
deux jours pendant les bombardements
incessants qui ont eu lieu je précise
que sur des habitations civiles
absolument pas sur des cibles
stratégiques il n'y a rien de militaire
il y a absolument rien de militaire dans
cette région
il s'attendent à ce que ça recommence
c'est-à-dire que moi ils m'ont fait
visiter les abris ils ont tout
réapprovisionné il y a l'eau ils ont
tout prévu c'est des choses des abris
très petits dans lesquels il vivait à 10
avec les enfants les bébés etc et
ce qui m'a frappé c'est que ils savent
que de toute façon on peut absolument
compter quand les armée de
c'est très important
j'accueille Jean rad vanille bonsoir
bienvenue sur géographe spécialiste du
Caucase et de la Russie professeur
émérite à l'Institut national des
langues et civilisations orientales
peut-être pour
je parlais du couloir de la Chine qui
est l'une des zones où il y a eu des
combats
il y a un peu plus d'un mois et demi en
quoi cette partie là et particulièrement
stratégique le couloir de la Chine c'est
le passage le plus favorable
entre le Karaba je rappelle que on
l'appelle le O Karaba ou le carabar
montagneuse c'est-à-dire c'est une
région de montagne on a des crêtes on a
des sommets à 3000 mètres donc c'est une
région de montagne donc on peut pas
passer n'importe où il faut utiliser
l'école il faut utiliser les vallées et
le couloir de la Chine c'est le c'est la
partie qui était en Azerbaïdjan
en dehors du carabar et qui permettait
de relier par la route l'Arménie
proprement dite à la région du Caraba et
cette ce couloir de la Chine a été
pris placé pris par les forces
arméniennes pendant la guerre entre 14
en 92 93 et depuis cette date il était
rattaché donc
au territoire arménien sous contrôle de
l'Arménie et il a été perdu pendant la
guerre en 2020
et du coup
lors du cessez-le-feu on a proposé un
passage différent plus au nord entre
l'Arménie et les régions qui restent
sous contre l'arménien du carbare
on va pas trop rentrer dans le détail
pour ceux qui connaissent pas aussi bien
que vous la carte de de cette région
alors je voudrais ouvrir un chapitre
consacré à la Turquie et pour ça je vous
propose d'écouter
ce que dit la députée renaissance des
Bouches-du-Rhône Anne Laurence Petel
c'était lors des questions au
gouvernement à l'Assemblée le 4 octobre
dernier je veux vous parler d'une guerre
dont personne ne parle aussi peu je veux
vous parler de l'Arménie envahie par
l'Azerbaïdjan le 13 septembre dernier
l'Arménie dont les frontières
souveraines et internationalement
reconnu ont été violées l'Arménie
victime d'une véritable guerre de
conquête aujourd'hui 50 km2 de son
territoire sont déjà occupés par Bakou
qui a lancé ses troupes à l'assaut du
sud de l'Arménie deux ans après la
guerre du haut Karaba et qui porte avec
Erdogan le paon Turquie un projet de
réunion des peuples turcophones dans un
empire où le peuple arménien n'a pas sa
place le régime alzéri multiplie les
exactions il torture mutilent à bout
portant des soldats prisonniers
l'épreuve sont là personne ne pourra
dire qu'il ne savait pas
genre advenise avec vous sur l'influence
turque dans dans ce que cette région du
monde est en train de vivre est-ce qu'il
y a une main turque derrière la volonté
de l'Azerbaïdjan de de d'envahir ses
territoires une main turque en tout cas
c'est un allié depuis toujours et ce qui
est certain c'est que la Turquie a un
rêve le rêve pan turc effectivement ce
rêve c'est d'avoir une continuité
territoriale entre la Turquie proprement
dit et tous les pays tur qui sont plus à
l'Est ça commence par l'Azerbaïdjan puis
au-delà de la Caspienne 4 des états de
l'Asie centrale et au-delà d'autres
terres en Sibérie
aussi en Chine le nord de la Chine le
cynthiangle etc or dans cette dans ce
rêve de continuité territoriale il
manque un passage qui est l'Arménie
puisque l'Arménie le sud de l'Arménie le
zanguezo ou le sunique est à une
frontière commune avec l'Iran et et ça
c'est un élément absolument stratégique
dont les Arméniens évidemment que les
Arméniens veulent absolument
contrôlés et de même que et la Russie et
l'Iran
je rappelle quand même parce que ça
c'est intéressant il y a eu une
tentation tentative américaine de
proposer un échange territorial entre ce
fameux couloir de la Chine dont on
parlait contre le sud de dans les années
80 à la fin des années 90 des diplomates
américains ont proposé un échange de
territoires qui aurait coupé l'Arménie
de l'Iran or il faut quand même bien
rappeler que c'est un ce que c'est les
Arméniens l'appellent le feu un des
chemins de la vie c'est à dire que ceux
ce sud de l'Arménie et cette frontière
avec l'Iran est une un des seuls
passages par lequel
l'approvisionnement de l'Arménie le gaz
l'électricité peuvent passer puisque
comme vous le savez l'Arménie est
totalement enclavée elle est enclavée
géographiquement c'est-à-dire qu'elle
n'a pas de contact avec la mère et elle
est enclavée politiquement puisque la
frontière turque est fermée et la
frontière azerbaïdjanaise est en guerre
des factos
de genre Advani je me dis petit pays aux
prises avec des géants autour de autour
de lui c'est un peu ce sentiment quand
on parle là de la Turquie on va parler
de la Russie après
et petit pays qui se sent depuis un mois
et demi abandonné c'est comme ça que
vous le ressentez je dirais qu'il est
pas abandonné depuis un mois et demi
mais depuis bien plus longtemps avant
l'Arménie ça me fait le royaume des
trois mères vous voyez quand même comme
ça a changé
depuis j'allais dire les les
trajets dit de l'histoire et notamment
depuis le génocide de 1915 qui a
concerné l'Arménie et tous les chrétiens
d'Orient parce que il y a eu aussi ce
génocide en même temps en Irak et en
Syrie actuelle donc aujourd'hui
effectivement la question qu'on peut se
poser est-ce que la vie des Arméniens
vaut-elle moins que celle des Ukrainiens
puisque nous sommes mobilisés matin midi
et soir sur l'Ukraine à juste titre mais
on ne parle pas de l'Arménie de la même
façon que pendant la guerre des 44 jours
c'était silence radio et s'il n'y avait
pas eu le Parlement pour un peu sauver
l'honneur et la diplomatie française
puisqu'à l'époque le ministre Le Drian
des Affaires étrangères parler de
neutralité disons nous nous sommes dans
parti prenante dans les accords de mixte
c'est-à-dire les États-Unis la Russie et
la France pour l'Arménie pour la ksark
notamment donc on intervient pas mais
comme disait Desmond toutou être neutre
chez soi GIR son camp on peut pas
choisir celui de la barbarie et on a
laissé les Arméniens être massacrés
pendant 44 jours avec des bombes à des
fragmentations des bombophosphore et des
exactions abominables c'est la Russie
qui a mis un terme avec tous les comment
dire
avec ces visées très particulières et
d'ailleurs dans les accords de la guerre
des 44 jours on voit bien que les
soldats
russes étaient là pour maintenir la paix
et moi je me suis rendu en arts que je
crois qu'on a fait partie de la première
délégation à cette rendue en arc Sark
après la guerre des 44 jours et quand on
passait parmi ce fameux corridor de la
Chine et notamment dans la ville de
sushi appelé maintenant sous chat par
les la série on voyait les soldats
zerriches comme je vois là il y avait
même pas à mettre un mètre 50 de mètres
des drapeaux Azéris partout des armes
dans tous les sens et ont passé 5-6-7
chaque point pour aller dans cette
enclave plutôt dans cette esclave parce
que c'est plus ça le lac ça aussi en
reste avec des gens qui avaient subi le
pire et qui savait très bien même les
Arméniens savaient très bien que
aujourd'hui
le fait de perdre le Karaba c'est perdre
l'eau il y a quatre sources pour pour
Caraba pour pour l'eau donc 4 et
notamment l'irrigation du lac Sévan qui
est la grande ressource d'eau de
l'Arménie et puis surtout la perte de ce
poumon que pouvait être
l'arc Sarthe maintenant aujourd'hui
j'allais dire c'est pire encore puisque
c'est sur le territoire de la République
d'Arménie que se passe les attaques et
notamment cette volonté de l'Azerbaïdjan
de couper le sud de l'Arménie on le
voyait tout à l'heure sur la carte
ce petit bout qui la relie à l'Iran et
effectivement qui est une respiration
pour l'Arménie qui est entourée
d'ennemis féroce qui qui disent de façon
totalement j'allais dire décomplexé
qu'ils veulent les exterminer
c'est quand même incroyable d'entendre
ça et de recevoir comme chef d'État ces
personnes pour les personnes qui nous
écoutent il faut savoir que après la
guerre des 44 jours il y a ma lief qui
reçoit en grande pompe et notamment qui
sert la main de Madame
Ursula vanderleyen et je comprends que
moi franchement ça m'a extrêmement
heurté il a fait un parc des trophées
à bas coût vous savez ce que c'est le
parc des trophées c'était exactement ce
que faisait les nazis avec des objets
ramassés sur les arbres enfin sur des
Arméniens des caricatures d'Arméniens où
on faisait défiler les enfants pour
cracher sur eux voilà ce que c'est le
parc des trophées un chef d'État qui
fait ça après avoir massacré ne pas
avoir rendu les prisonniers et qui est
reçu en grande pompe par Madame ursella
vanderleyen qui dit que c'est un allié
sûr et fiable il y a quand même de quoi
être particulièrement choqué on y
reviendra cette question du gaz mais je
voudrais vous y fait beaucoup excuse pas
tout non
vous faites souvent référence à cette
guerre des 44 jours donc on est en
2026500 morts selon les chiffres
officiels Valérie thoragnan c'est quasi
impossible d'y aller dans cette dans
cette partie du haut karabaro
aujourd'hui vous avez essayé à plusieurs
reprises c'est impossible aujourd'hui il
y a plus de Français qui rentrent dans
cette région les journalistes c'est
impossible donc
c'est une région fermée et dans le drame
de vie aujourd'hui l'Arménie où on voit
bien que ce verrou du sud de l'Arménie
ce qui est très bien été expliqué tout à
l'heure c'est à dire que cette idée de
couper de faire sauter le verrou et de
pouvoir enfin réaliser cet espace
peinture que
on
voit bien aujourd'hui la menace qui pèse
directement sur l'Arménie mais alors la
situation du Karaba elle est encore plus
isolée c'est à dire plus personne ne
rentre il y a très peu d'informations il
y a il y a une impossibilité même pour
des délégations culturelles etc de s'y
rendre et pour les politiques aussi donc
un sentiment d'isolement total une
angoisse chez ses habitants aussi que
finalement
il fasse les frais à un moment donné des
négociations il y a une manifestation à
Stéphane Agathe qui a réuni dimanche
dernier ou samedi je sais plus
plus de 40 000 personnes sur un
territoire qui aujourd'hui il doit
rester à peu près entre 110 120 130 000
Arméniens 40
000 dollars pour dire si jamais
l'Azerbaïdjan
occupe l'intégralité de ce territoire
nous on est mort c'est-à-dire que soit
on va être pourchasser soit on va être
tué soit surtout on fuira parce que à un
moment donné il faut fuir les exactions
donc le nettoyage ethnique en fait c'est
ça c'est soit en vous tue soit on vous
menace dans les villages où j'étais à la
frontière il racontait que par exemple
pendant soi-disant des périodes où il y
avait des cessez le feu et personne
n'était censé tirer il est depuis les
postes de tir azerbaïdjanais ils
envoyaient des meules de enflammés sur
les récoltes des paysans ce qui
faisaient que toutes les récoltes
étaient fichues ils envoyaient ils
allumaient des énormes projecteurs la
nuit et lancer des messages pour dire
fuyez fuyer parce que toute façon vous
en sortirez pas donc il y a une pression
psychologique sur eux et le but c'est
qu'il s'en aille leurs rêves c'est qu'il
s'en aille sans même qu'ils aient livré
bataille et encore une fois et que ce
territoire soit définitivement vidée de
ces Arméniens et c'est une partie encore
du territoire arménien historique de
cette population historique qui diminue
comme peau de chagrin comme peau de
chagrin et ça fait depuis 1915
et même avant mais en tout cas depuis il
y a une continuité une opération de
nettoyage ethnique et une continuité
voilà et avec un rôle de la Russie sur
lequel on peut revenir parce qu'il est
on ne peut plus troubler on peut y
revenir même historiquement genre à
Denis parce que c'est vrai quand on
regarde la carte on voit ce territoire
je reste sur le hautbar qui est
complètement enclavé dans le territoire
de l'Azerbaïdjan ça date de quand ça
date de Staline c'est c'est quoi
l'expédition alors c'est Staline
effectivement qui a décidé des
frontières de l'Azerbaïdjan et de
l'Arménie et qui a décidé que et le
Karaba et le Narry de chez Vans de
région voisine mais séparée aujourd'hui
par la par la par l'Arménie
serait sous la tutelle de l'Azerbaïdjan
et évidemment alors cette décision a été
contestée plus tard pas sous Staline
mais elle est restée en vigueur jusqu'en
et la guerre qui a eu la première guerre
importante entre 91 et 94 a fait que les
forces arméniennes ont pris le contrôle
de tout le cas de presque tout le Caraba
et de tous les territoires qui entourent
le Caraba entre le carabarès et
l'Arménie et entre le Carambar et l'Iran
si bien que et ces territoires
leur statut n'a jamais été
définie c'est-à-dire que politiquement
il y a des frontières qui sont encore
floues c'est frontières sont encore
floues d'autant plus que comme les
Arméniens contrôlaient tous les
territoires de part et d'autre de la
frontière entre l'Arménie et
l'Azerbaïdjan ils ne se sont pas
réellement soucier de faire une
démarcation de ces territoires
c'est assez moi je montrais ça à mes
étudiants
l'Atlas national de l'Arménie a inclu
tous ces territoires comme s'ils étaient
Arméniens sans aucune sans aucune
contestation or après 1994 il y a eu un
cessé le feu
il était absolument clair Baku a
toujours dit
Alif père puis Alif fils on dit si il
n'y a pas de règlement politique sur ces
territoires nous les reprendrons par la
force et malheureusement je dirais quand
même le pouvoir ménien ne s'est pas
vraiment soucier de de trouver ce
compromis politique nécessaire vous y a
une occasion manquée à ce moment il y a
eu plusieurs occasions manquées il y a
une occasion manquée en 96 97 le
président arménien de l'époque
terpetrosian a engagé des pourparlers et
il a envisagé de restituer à
l'Azerbaïdjan quelques-uns des districts
qui avaient été
sous le contrôle de l'Arménie pendant
des forces arméniennes en 94 lors du
ccfeu sauf que il a été critiqué pour
cela et on l'a poussé à la démission ce
qui fait que pendant 20 ans ce des
dirigeants du karabach qui ont dirigé
l'Arménie proprement dites et il y a eu
une deuxième occasion manquée cette
fois-ci c'est une proposition de l'OSCE
à la conférence de Madrid et de nouveau
en fait on est dans une situation
pendant 20 ans ou tantôt l'Arménie
tantôt l'Azerbaïdjan récusait toutes les
propositions de compromis politiques et
pendant ce temps-là
l'Azerbaïdjan s'armait avec l'argent du
pétrole l'argent du gaz jusqu'en 2020 où
il est passé à l'attaque
les Arméniens ont occupé des territoires
qui étaient des territoires autour du
carabar parce que pour eux c'était
évidemment un outil de négociation il a
jamais été question pour eux même si les
il y avait des atlas qui englobaient
certes mais il était il a toujours été
question que ces territoires soient une
monnaie d'échange parce qu'à un moment
donné ce qui était le plus important
pour les Arméniens c'était qu'il y a une
garantie du statut de cette région du la
barre pour que les Arméniens même si
elle n'est pas un rattachement en termes
de droit international mais en tout cas
que la question du statut qui était
extrêmement importante soit réglée comme
les azerbaï généreusé toujours
systématiquement d'aborder cette
question du statut en disant il n'y a
pas de question de statut cette
intérêtoire azerbaïdjanais etc c'est
vrai que les négociations ont été
compliquées et par ailleurs vous avez
raison il les abeilles j'en s’armais et
par ailleurs quel crédit on pouvait
accorder si vous voulez à la parole
azerbaïgenèse sachant que toute cette
histoire du au caramar a commencé
rappelons-le quand même par des pogromes
qui ont eu lieu en 87 88 90 absolument
pas dans le caramar mais en azerbait les
gens contre les Arméniens parce que les
Arméniens avaient d'une façon tout à
fait conforme à la Constitution demander
justement que la région est un statut
autonome ou soit rattaché à l'Arménie
donc c'est très complexe il y a sûrement
eu des occasions manquées mais il y a
aussi une décision
enfin il y a
ne veut absolument pas entendre parler
de
quelconque statut qui soit pour cette
région du haut-karaba il considère que
c'est chez eux
ils considère que les églises
arméniennes qui sont sur le territoire
du haut-karaba en fait il vous explique
d'une manière très sérieuse que ce sont
pas du tout des églises arméniennes qui
sont là depuis des millénaires mais des
églises ou des siècles mais des églises
albanaises du cocase qui n'ont rien à
voir avec les Arméniens ils sont en
train de faire une réécriture de
l'histoire de la géographie de du
patrimoine pour justifier que ces terres
soient et puis finalement en faisant
peur aux populations on va les chasser
et tout rentrera dans l'ordre donc je
suis d'accord qu'il y a eu des occasions
il y a toujours des occasions manquées
il faut le déplorer mais après il faut
voir qui on a en face et la complexité
aussi que c'était pour les Arméniens
d'arriver à obtenir la garantie et c'est
là que je voudrais qu'on revienne juste
un petit peu sur les Russes parce que ça
fait quand même dans cette région depuis
des décennies depuis j'allais dire même
avant
96 97 depuis le début de cette guerre
depuis le début de ce conflit où il joue
un rôle qui ne vise en fait qu'à
s'assurer que ils maintiennent
suffisamment de tension pour que rien ne
se règle dans la région et qu'il soit
éternellement les maîtres des horloges
et ceux qui font qui défend ce qui doit
ce qui doit se passer Poutine qui est
quand même occupé avec sa guerre en
Ukraine il a foncé à Sotchi histoire de
dire les images je suis là je suis là
je suis Poutine c'est ma zone
d'influence c'est le Caucase c'est moi
qui déciderai là on va faire si on va
faire ça les deux se sont dit qu'il
s'attaqueraient pas donc j'estime que
j'ai remporté un succès diplomatique
mais comme je dis souvent les Russes
soutiennent l'Arménie comme la corde
soutient le pendu c'est à dire que il
de fait pendant la guerre des 44 jours
ils sont ils ont mis fin à la guerre au
moment où voilà les azerbes générales à
peu près obtenu tout ce qui voulait donc
c'est très compliqué pour les Arméniens
des deux pays de ne pas recourir la
force on se dit ça ça gèle une situation
dans laquelle 50 km² ont été ont été
pris par l'azerba jan-guillaume
politique c'est aussi une réponse de
Poutine à ce qui s'était passé à Prague
au début du mois d'octobre ou Emmanuel
Macron avait mis en scène le fait
d'avoir passé la nuit et réussir à
mettre autour de la table le présent de
l'Azerbaïdjan le président arménien et
le président du Conseil européen pour
aboutir à une proposition qui est
d'envoyer une mission d'observateur
européen pour aider à la délimitation
des frontières entre les deux pays et
Emmanuel Macron qui en avait d'ailleurs
remis une couche la semaine dernière sur
France 2 en disant qu'il ne lâcherait
pas
les Arméniens et pointant d'ailleurs le
du doigt le rôle de la Russie ce qui a
pas été apprécié et ce qui a d'ailleurs
été publiquement dit par le ministère
des Affaires étrangères russes en disant
que Emmanuel Macron ferait mieux de se
mêler de ce qui se passait en France
Emmanuel Macron qui avait aussi on va
écouter une réaction du président
français c'était le 26 septembre dernier
il reçoit le premier ministre arménien
Nicole pachinian à l'Elysée on écoutait
Emmanuel Macron puisque des positions
ont été conquises la France a demandé
que les forces
azerbaïdjanaises reviennent à leur
position initiale je l'ai dit
dès le 14 septembre au président Alif
le fait que la frontière ne soit pas
délimitée ne saurait justifier des
avancées sur le territoire de l'autre
pays la France à la conviction que le
recours à la force ne peut être la
solution pour l'Arménie pas plus que
pour l'Azerbaïdjan et que le dialogue
doit être rétabli sans délai
Valérie Boyer vous dites quoi service
minimum de la part de diplomatie
française
44 jours mais à ce moment là on avait
des moyens d'agir qui était supérieures
à ceux qu'on a aujourd'hui parce que
quand vous allez à Stéphane hacker comme
quand vous allez aérer van ben vous ne
voyez que des tombes d'enfants de 18 20
ans enfin c'est absolument abominable
parce que ça c'est la cicatrice de la
guerre des 44 jours et à ce moment-là
personne n'a rien fait alors
effectivement les Azerbaïdjanais sont
pas fous ils sont intervenus pendant les
élections américaines bon toujours au
bon moment pour que personne
n'intervienne avec la complicité et
l'aide militaire très forte de la
Turquie et pas d'aide internationale et
silence international moi je pense que
la France aurait pu faire plus notamment
pendant que elle avait la présidence de
l'Union européenne et la France était
partie prenante des accords de mix donc
c'était à ce moment là qu'on aurait dû
agir on ne l'a pas fait donc aujourd'hui
effectivement maintenant je regrette
qu'on aille pas plus loin pourquoi pas
de force d'interposition aujourd'hui
franchement envoyer des observateurs
quand on sait au millimètre près où sont
les gens
c'est juste bon c'est histoire de dire
qu'on fait quelque chose mais il y a
rien de concret qui se passe et il faut
pas oublier que ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en Arménie et au Karaba
c'est pas le seul dessin d'Erdogan et de
son ami Alif hein ils sont très clairs
souvenez-vous avant d'intervenir en
arcsart ils avaient fait des tentatives
à Chypre et il y a eu un accord qui a
été passé entre la Turquie l'Azerbaïdjan
et le Pakistan pour trois territoires
pour l'AXA fallait au Caraba Chypre et
le Cachemire et où Erdogan et à Liège
ont fêté la victoire sur le Karaba et
ben il en fêté à barre au chat à Chypre
en zone neutre ce qui est quand même une
provocation
extrêmement importante
vis-à-vis de l'Union européenne et qui
les dessins de d'Erdogan sont très
claires et revendiquent des îles enfin
une île grecque en particulier mais bon
cette partie là il revendique Chypre il
revendique le Karaba parce qu'il est
dans son délire peinture Kiss parce
qu'on parle là de vers la Chine mais il
y a aussi de l'autre côté et le fait
qu'on s'aide et qu'on que qu'il n'y ait
pas de réaction internationale pendant
la guerre des 44 jours et qui est un
silence total aujourd'hui ou quasi total
sur ce qui se passe en Arménie bien ça
le j'allais dire que ça leur donne des
ailes
allez on termine il nous reste un peu
moins de 8 minutes sur ce cette accord
sur le gaz vous l'avez évoqué plusieurs
fois et évidemment je voulais consacrer
du temps
juillet dernier
Ursule avant de la hyène la présidente
de la Commission européenne elle est à
bas coût elle signe avec le président
EDF un accord pour multiplier par deux
les importations regardez
a décidé de se diversifier loin de la
Russie et de se tourner vers des
partenaires plus fiables et dignes de
confiance je suis heureuse de compter
l'Azerbaïdjan parmi eux
disent les Arméniens je rappelle que
vous y étiez à 15 jours et donc vous
avez pu voilà directement
les rencontrer entendre leur réaction
qu'est-ce qu'ils disent de cet accord il
le connaissent tous dans le moindre
village de 153 habitants il connaît sur
celui-là wonderlingen et à chaque fois
ils disent mais vous allez pas sacrifier
les Arméniens à cause du gaz ils le
disent d'autant plus avec justesse c'est
que il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui c'est
une des 30 sources d'approvisionnement
pour l'Europe le gaz azerbaïdjanais
c'est pas si important que ça alors que
pour les orbé Jean c'est très important
d'exporter vers l'Europe et que donc il
y avait pas besoin pour Madame Ursula
vanderlain d'aller se s'incliner devant
le dictateur à l'if en disant en faisant
croire que c'était un allié sociable
blessures et en ce
félicitant regardez j'ai été chercher du
gaz et je pense à à tous nos européens
qui vont qui ne manqueront pas de
chauffage pour Noël cet hiver donc c'est
doublement honteux et
cet accord
voilà aujourd'hui on est enfin on est
dans une tarterie incroyable parce que
la Turquie exporte du gaz
qui vient de Russie et qu'elle exporte
ensuite elle vers l'Europe en s'en
vantant elle aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux alors je croyais que le gaz
russe était
enfin qui devait qu'on n'exporter pour
qu'on apportait plus de gaz russe mais
via la Turquie on continue en importer
donc tout ça tout ça est ridicule ça ne
ça ne pèse pas vraiment mais en tout cas
symboliquement ça a été reçu avec une
violence incroyable par les Arméniens et
puis je vais vous dire une chose on a le
gaz azerbagenais il est pris qu'il soit
pris qu'il soit acheminés vers après
tout voilà mais qu'au moins ça serve de
monnaie de pour des négociations pour
pour
obtenir de l'azerbée de gens quelque
chose on vous prend votre gaz vous êtes
bien content de nous le vendre on est
bien content de le recevoir mais
maintenant voilà avançons sur cette
question là moi je je suis assez
stupéfaite parce que finalement on est
l'Europe et assez impuissante et elle je
pense qu'elle est volontairement
impuissante parce que il y a trop de
pays qui veulent surtout pas qu'on
commence à voilà à en venir mais les
choses côté Erdogan n'oubliez pas aussi
qu'il y a le robinet l'immigration et
que du côté de la Turquie on a toujours
peur des menaces que fait peser de Anne
sur l'Europe en disant attention moi
j'ai x millions d'immigrés chez moi si
je si je je de nouveau j'autorise et je
fais en sorte que ça arrive vous allez
être encore à venir me supplier à genoux
pour que je ferme les robinets donc
voilà il y a tous ces chantages qui sait
tout ce qui s'exerce et Emmanuel Macron
il essaie de faire des choses donc moi
je lui donne le crédit qu'il essaie de
faire des choses et je pense que il faut
qu'il aille beaucoup plus loin et qu'il
a une occasion là parce qu'en diplomatie
internationale c'est pas évident pour
lui en ce moment il a une belle occasion
de faire quelque chose de rentrer dans
l'histoire comme disait Sylvain Tesson
qui a été qui était en Arménie
d'ailleurs au moment où j'ai été aussi
de rentrer dans l'histoire et de faire
quelque chose qui qui fasse vraiment
avancer et qui débloque la situation et
le et les Arméniens d'Arménie attendent
la France vous savez ils accorde à la
France une importance comme à aucun
autre pays pour la France c'est le pays
des droits de l'homme c'est le pays qui
a été là pour les recueillir au moment
du génocide la parole française compte
et il l'attendent avec angoisse genre
alvanie ce gaz ce gaz
azerbaïdjanais effectivement c'est quoi
c'est la principale richesse du pays
c'est effectivement comme le dit
valérythorien beaucoup plus important
pour laserbaïdjan de l'exporter vers
l'Europe que pour l'Europe de 100 de
s'en saisir oui bien sûr c'est c'est la
principale ressource de l'Azerbaïdjan le
pétrole le gaz et c'est pour ça que
qu'on a qu'on a construit
plusieurs oléoduc et plusieurs gazoduc
qui permettent d'exporter le ces
hydrocarbures vers essentiellement
l'Union européenne en même temps
en fait il y a pas beaucoup de réserve
les réserves sont déjà au plafond donc
ça probablement laserbaïdjan ne pourra
pas livrer tellement plus de gaz à
l'Union européenne ce qui est un peu
consternant en fait c'est que depuis le
début dans cette affaire l'Union
Européenne a une position étrange en 92
93 ils ont signé des accords de
coopération avec l'Arménie et avec
l'Azerbaïdjan l'Union européenne et avec
Bakou avec l'Azerbaïdjan on a signé un
accord où on met en valeur l'intégrité
territoriale des pays et avec l'Arménie
on a signé un accord où on met en valeur
l'autodétermination des peuples c'est à
dire que on
valorise pour chacun celui des des
concepts internationaux qui lui sciez ce
qui est une façon évidemment alors qu'on
sait parfaitement qu'il y a un conflit
en cours donc c'est l'Union européenne
n'est pas très à l'aise dans cette
affaire et malheureusement je ne suis
pas du tout sûr que ça soit de ce côté
là que compte que des bouches une
solution politique le problème c'est
qu'il faut qu'il faut persuader les
opinions publiques de des deux pays de
faire les compromis nécessaires elle est
une minute pour terminer à vous le mot
de la conclusion vous vous réclamez le
gel des avoirs du président Alif et de
son clan quand vous entendez
dire fiable et digne de confiance et on
fait particulièrement bondir ça me fait
particulièrement bondir et c'est vrai
que j'ai un sentiment d'écoiement après
ces paroles parce que ça fait des années
que l'Azerbaïdjan pratique la diplomatie
de la menace toutes les personnes qui
sont allées en arc Sark et depuis très
longtemps depuis 10 ans ça fait
peut-être plus de 10 ans son personnel
en gratta donc on savait parfaitement à
qui on avait affaire je veux dire ils se
sont jamais dissimulés par contre nous
on sait toujours couché aujourd'hui il y
a des crimes de guerre c'est pas non
seulement c'est une guerre totalement
asymétrique mais avec des crimes de
guerre qui sont avérées qui sont
documentés des prisonniers qui ne sont
pas rendus on a tous vu cette vidéo
abominable de ces gamins les mains dans
le dos qui ont été tués comme des comme
des lapins par les guerriers azériques
et en plus ce film et qui sont très
fiers de leur forfait parce que tu as un
Arménien faut pas oublier qu'il les
traite comme des chiens c'est comme ça
qu'il parle de donc on a
on a affaire quand même des personnes
dont on connaît parfaitement les dessins
d'ailleurs il y a pas un seul arménien
qui peut survivre sous le joug ils sont
massacrés ils sont torturés donc on sait
parfaitement à qui on a affaire et
pourtant on agit pas et effectivement
Emmanuel Macron pourrait rentrer dans
l'histoire et ce serait peut-être
l'occasion pour la diplomatie européenne
d'exister et c'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui pourquoi parce que
l'Allemagne
et
être lié à la Turquie qui elle-même et
bien et le cerveau et les mains de
l'Azerbaïdjan on termine là-dessus merci
beaucoup
qui a tous d'avoir participé à ce débat
à bientôt sur sur public c'est na merci
Guillaume à bientôt on va trouvera
évidemment sur ce plateau avec plaisir
je vous donne rendez-vous demain
évidemment 18h22 heures les horaires de
diffusion de la Science Publique et puis
demain matin dans avec rien de Mancini
c'est vous voyez son son portrait
s'afficher son visage Agnès de la
transition énergétique qui sera l'invité
de la matinale à 8h salut
[Musique]